[Music]
failure to launch news oh that movie
yeah Martin Buber Kyle hey we gotta wear
this brute knife [ __ ] man you can't
hurt you still sharp like use this one
let me see Joe yeah that one you go yeah
yeah give him more toys to play with
good call but at least you won't get
hurt I know but he got rid of that toy
now he has another one look please play
with him more intense favorite because
he knows it's a toy yeah submitted by G
Pig Gigi eggs and ham some cheap eggs we
had feel oh God I couldn't have the real
one let me just get my people's kids a
drum set yeah I don't have anything
that's exactly what your kid's gonna do
what he goes no an account wait cuz I'm
gonna be like you can't get mad at him
here you go
give it back to the other time now do
you have a knife did you bring your
[ __ ] $100 paring knife here I was
eating a mango desperate parents are
seeking help from the court to evict
their 30 year old son from a family home
no my mom's friend it's going through
the same [ __ ]
yes to [ __ ] evict the kid so both on
my dad's side and on my mom's side you
know what an Asian for has always
compared kids yeah I was bottom of the
barrel the shittiest kid in the world
and now they're like you don't know how
good you have it rub it in their face
you'll be like you [ __ ]
you were never proud of me [ __ ]
they're like you don't know how good you
have it that your son moved out cuz
we're the first generation of
Millennials right I think it's a big
millennial problem right now why you
can't afford living in LA wait to leave
my [ __ ] house me too pregnant like I
was just like I'm out yeah I would have
got pregnant if I could technically I
already moved out first and then I got
pregnant but anyway I want to live with
my mom she's awesome like I understand
living with your parents when you're
saving up for something like you're
working you get it and there's like a
goal yeah or if it's by choice - yeah
like I'm gonna save money here mm-hmm
just like your parents are willing to
help you in your goals yeah I I
completely understand that but that's
another [ __ ] dude Sarah Jessica Parker's
business in failure to launch
we probably work now well that no it
wasn't relevant her it was the other one
the one that you like with the bigger
one where your family's trying to evict
this is all enabling there they were
trying to evict them like legally yeah
it's [ __ ] green burn them but this
guy did some crazy [ __ ] what I'll tell
you after camera so instead it was right
it was Sarah Jessica Parker well so what
they ended up doing is just buying him
another house I can live on his own
which further enables his behavior
that's like rewarding him yeah and and a
victim no we're not paying rents he
lives in that house now we were thinking
of How to Lose a Guy in 10 days that's
Kate Hudson oh yeah
so it was Sarah Jessica Parker I
remember her roommate was additionnal in
that movie and I thought and that was
the first time I ever saw her
Zooey discharge is so funny so this
takes place in the state of New York
this is the home dan is a big driveway I
would paint my own full court basketball
court there oh well
yep you know what though it's like the
parents created this they didn't teach
them how to become independent and then
they're like sitting there waiting for
them to grow up and then not only that
but in the process of trying to get them
to leave yeah in my opinion they're way
enabler like what are they doing I have
a family member that's really close to
me that does that mm-hmm who your sister
yeah doesn't understand she still has
like all her [ __ ] still like in her room
yeah I'm like why doesn't this [ __ ]
didn't [ __ ] him over [ __ ] out was like
okay she likes to sleep here from time
to time I'm like she's [ __ ] married
Oh weird
right it's really weird it's not weird
if it's the only child no she's the
youngest Oh youngest child yeah damn
weird burger sister hey you're the one I
call you out there was two of them you
couldn't guess which one of us Oh true
nobody knows me I'm your sister Dina my
other truth in this article there are
five letters that they wrote to their
son trying to get him to move
well you [ __ ] five [ __ ] do first
one February 2nd my call Michael can you
read it can you read it read it read it
my cold after a discussion with your
mother we all it's different okay
Michael after a discussion with your
mother we have decided that you must
leave this house immediately you have 14
days to vacate you will not be allowed
to return we will take whatever actions
are necessary to enforce this decision
mark and Cristina rock doll doll that
was the first one right yeah February
2nd next one February 13th I feel like
Michael just win [ __ ] you dad
yep yeah [ __ ] you bill exactly hit the
first day yeah you Richard I know you're
a government name I told you I'm in the
process mm-hmm you're my [ __ ] dad
you're gonna [ __ ] evict your only
child
yeah what kind of parents are you Robert
I think it's more excuse making like
like oh no I'll be out I just gotta do
this
yeah I just gotta get this not even
because the letters they mention that
like you have made no effort so it says
now it says Michael Joseph Rotundo
you are hereby evicted from the address
effective immediately you have to hear
hear or to Forbin our guests and there
is no lease or agreement that gives you
any right to stay here without our
consent on the advice of our lawyer we
have decided to grant you up to 30 days
from the date shown above to remove your
possessions and vacate the premises
a legal enforcement procedure will be
instituted immediately if you do not
leave by 15th of March 2018 any action
that you take that can be construed as
threatening or harassing to us or
prevents or obstructs our ability to use
the house or property at 4:08 weather
Ridge Drive they keep their address as
we see fit will result in your immediate
removal from the premises
Christina Christina Burton the owner of
408 weather Ridge Drive that just sounds
like this buck had to like did some
physical [ __ ] to their parents - or
they're like they're scared now like
let's say they'll give them 30 I mean I
guess maybe that's legal like by the law
the advice of a lawyer yeah I wonder if
they like stick the letter on his mail
it to themself and they go here you got
a letter the first one was on February
2nd and they said 14 days this is only
11 days later cuz he's taking no action
so then the next one says On February
18th
Michael here is $1100 from us so you can
find a place to stay some advice number
one organize the things you need for
work and to manage an apartment note you
will need stuff at Paul Avenue you must
arrange a date and time through your
father so you can set it up with the
tenant to sell the other things you have
but have any significant belly yeah
tools this is especially true for any
weapons you may have you need some money
and you will have no place for this
stuff 3 there are jobs available even
for those with a poor work history like
you oh yeah why is he has to work for if
you want help finding a place your
mother has offered to help you I wish I
had really nice parents like this
they're really nice they're not nice in
the long run this is so detrimental yeah
I feel like
parents are like this like I want to
tell him something knock on the door
Michael and he goes get the [ __ ] away
she's like alright let me give you money
they're just training him that don't
listen to our words yeah because our
actions say otherwise yep they're our
actions will always support you and
you're in no danger of any real
consequence yeah even though our words
say you are yes so now March 5th Michael
today is March 5th 2018 you have 11 days
to vacate the address along with your
property so far we have seen no
indication that you are preparing to
leave if you are forced to leave you
risk having your property put out of the
house and we will bear no responsibility
for its disposition your mom will put in
the garage for you and should I make you
some cookies yeah yeah apple pie in the
oven I love you I love you love you
sweetie and I watched her BMW pretty
that's all yeah so that other letter
said that you must leave by March 15th
right now we're at March 30th
Michael you have three acceptable
options regarding your vehicle both
lacking facade you can work on the card
inspector the necessary repairs we may
offer your financial assistant for this
I'm dying right now you can take the car
to a repair facility to get it fixed we
may offer you financial on my ah three
get the vehicle off the property if it
cannot be repaired we will pay for its
removal unless you are going to work on
the car immediately get it off the ramps
that was the last letter I would hate to
date this guy so what happened they're
gonna buy this guy a house yeah they're
gonna move out leave him the house
yeah that's what happened with them they
left the house with him it's a two-story
house and they bought another house Wow
and they move themselves out I hope they
lift the house on fire with them inside
too much follows that's too much bolster
yeah so now they've gone to the top
County Court you [ __ ] try to get help
this is like parents did this here's
life they deserve it you guys might not
agree with me but it's like these
parents made the choice to have a kid
right and it's kind of [ __ ] up that
all of a sudden they're just like they
want to be hands-off because it's too
much now but this is something that's
accumulated over so many years they
clear the ears they created this monster
right now they want him out and it's
like that's your [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ] decided to have a kid yep
stick with it not only knowledge but
like you really yeah exactly well you
decided to have this person even if he's
thirty that's still abandoning your kid
yep you have to train your kid to be an
individual - right - take the
consequences of your actions and they
enabled this [ __ ] yeah when you're a
figure of authority and you say this
will happen to you if this doesn't have
if you don't do this and then that
person doesn't do that you go well
here's some money instead I just had a
conversation with my friend last night
albeit I was a little drunk she was
mentioning that she has a kid and
they're splitting time between two
parents right because they split but
that child knows that Mommy is fun
parent they could do whatever they want
and so that kid when they go to the
daddy's house doesn't want to go and so
that kid just has this thing of like
okay I'll just like risk you here and I
could do whatever the hell I want so I
asked her so why don't you be a parent a
little bit - but you know we're friends
and stuff I just I know I can't do it I
was like whoa I was like just to put it
in perspective right now I was like just
because I grew up around a lot of kids
you know I worked at a lot of churches
like I've seen kids like that at church
and they always grow up to be the worst
kids because they know what they can get
away Leslie do you think your kids are
gonna be little yeah do you think of
kids marks go super-intelligent
cool they know what they're doing yeah
you know and she well I'll do it when
they're like five or six when they under
no no no they know now mm-hmm
they probably knew when they were one
years old and so you've been like
training them to do whatever the [ __ ]
that they want I was like when you try
to punish them what happens they're like
doesn't listen no I know what you're
talking about yeah you know a [ __ ]
tiger no but you know like she was like
she understands you know I mean I was
like you know like I don't have a kid at
whatever whatnot so I I don't
it feels weird for me to say that
however if you already know it and
you're already putting out there then is
URI know it's already funny so me just
kind of like saying it I mean come on
like what do you use being a mirror yeah
I'm just being a mirror to what you're
already saying you know what it means so
it's like if you're not that if you
think that it's gonna be fixed at six
but you're not starting it now it's like
it's not gonna happen that way
like you said yourself do kid smart and
here she's really cute
oh I mean the parents need something
like get a u-haul and when he goes
wherever to chill just [ __ ] move
everything out and then have like a
u-haul sale
yeah change the locks
comes back it's like what's your
property it's done home yeah you know
[ __ ] you're just go about Felicia
yeah
[Music]